في حاله من الغضب ماليا منصات العراقيه
والسبب مقطع فيديو منتشر بشكل كبير لمدرس
بهين الطالبات
عاديه
ان شاء الله تجيب
ان شاء الله
اثنين عائشه عدي
ليش
الورقه يلا طلعي
[موسيقى]
الفصل السادس
ما تطبين بفصل سادس واذا تريدين
اخر وحده
حباب وحلو على 49 من خمسين
[موسيقى]
واطرد غسق منير
وين
انت
شار المقطع بدات المعلومات تطلع وتضح انه
متصور في احد المعاهد الخاصه وانه اللي
ظاهر في المقطع مدرس كيمياء قالوا ناس انه
اسمه حسين الهاشمي والفيديو صورته خلص
احدى الطالبات الفيديو انتشر من هنا
وانفجر الناس من هنا انتقادات ومطالبات
بمحاسبه الاستاذ اللي شايفين انه اهان
الطالبات من غير وجه حق وصاروا يدعوا
الاحترام الرساله التعليميه
موضوع ان المعهد خاص زاد من غضب الناس
اللي شافت انه يعني هدول الطالبات اهاليهم
تفعيل فلوس عشان دروس خصوصيه يتعلموا فيها
مو علشان ينهانوا وفي اخرين شافوا انه
معهد خاص او حكومه الموضوع مرفوض وسيء في
كلتا الحالتين طبعا عموما امام حاله الغضب
هذه تحلت او تحركت السلطات فعلا ووزير
التربيه امر بتشكيل لجنه تحقيق عاجله حول
المقطع ووصفوا بانه في تعامل بطريقه بعيده
عن السمات التربويه مكتب الوزير امها
للجنه التحقيقيه 48 ساعه لتعلن نتائج
تحقيقها واكد انه ما بيسمح لاحد بالمساس
بالطلبه مهما كانت الاسباب والتصرف معاهم
بطريقه هوجه واكد الوزير على قدسيه مهنه
التعليم ورسالتها الانسانيه والاخلاقيه
وان اللي متورط بافعال من هذه لا يستحق
الصفه التربويه اللي بيحملها وامر الوزير
كمان باغلاق المعاهد اللي بتخالف قوانين
الوزاره ومبادئ الشرف المهنه تعليميه